it's hard not to feel a little lost as
we begin
let's just take it all in
when's the last time you heard someone
say something bad interesting
there's nothing like having the one you
hold dearest nearest When The World
Turns cold
thanks for going to a special place with
me Carl norkel
I'm always moving forward just on to the
next don't let Fame bring out the worst
in you I want to taste the cheese
how is everything excuse
me good thing
hi friends and welcome to paint with
Ambrosia it takes paint to a whole new
place
[Music]
you're entitled to your favorite TV show
what makes this country great
you want to touch my sandals oh Carl
[Music]
foreign